[Musique]
j'ai posé une question qui me touche et
qui me concerne je suis médecin
il ya quarante ans j'ai passé le
concours de première année de médecine
des milliers de personnes en france
confort très difficile et est basée sur
les questions écrites faire médecine
c'est neuf mois d'apprentissage
neuf mois on laisse de côté sa vie et
cette année les modalités de concours
changé
puisqu'il y à un oral de quelques
minutes et 1 ora qui comptent pour 70%
et orale sur des questions de société
les questions dans certaines villes sur
le web sur le racisme et même à paris
sur la barrière de corail
est à paris à 42 étudiants qui étaient
en haut du classement
qui se sont retrouvés déclassé et il y a
beaucoup d'étudiants qui n'espérait pas
à réussir et qui vont être médecin c'est
ça a été l'abattoir pour ses quarante
deux personnes chez hugo téléphone ce
sont des gens je sais plus ce sont des
gens
c'est dégueulasse
sipa les images que je me fais de la
france mais là on a vu une
ministre qui porte un beau nom parce que
vidal c'est le nom du dictionnaire
qu'utilisent les médecins mais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'elle a ouvert une seule
fois en finale et elle a prouvé encore
une fois qu'elle était complètement
déconnecté ces mots mes mots sont durs
mais mes mots sont les mots de l'émotion
d'un médecin qui sait ce que c'est que
veut passer par les fourches caudines
d'un grand pour devise républicaine
liberté égalité
fraternité égalité au principe de la
diversité par nos on veut des personnes
compétentes et là y'a pas tracts et
redouté que la fraternité c'est sait
écouter
c'est accepter de changer d
accepter d'être
d'avoir des piqûres de lutte
[Musique]